okay so I'm going to talk a little bit
about the border serum that you've heard
a lot already about a few times in this
a workshop so let me start with the
basic kind of questions that border is
trying to answer and here's an explicit
question if you wish about auctions but
it's really all just a plain question
about probabilities so we're selling one
item and two players we have each one
can have these are a low value or a high
value we don't care what the low value
or high value or sort of abstracting
away and the question is can you design
any auction where you win if you have a
lower value when its probability thirty
percent if you have a high value you win
with probability seven people sent and
I'm only talking about can you get the
probabilities to work out don't worry
about any games or strategies or
anything like that but i have my own
yeah okay so can you do that so what do
we need to do basically we need to fill
and probabilities for any combination of
values of the players we need to fill
what is the probability the first guy
wins what is the probability the second
guy wins okay the column player wins
with this probabilities of the role
player with that probability the sum of
these two has to be one and by the way
i'm assuming uniform equal probability
lnh and what I need this is the total
probability that the role player wins
0.3 has to be the averages of these two
numbers and the total probability let's
say that this guy wins when he has high
values average of these numbers so can
you throw the question marks so you get
the visa averages and the answer is yes
you can so here's one solution good so
can you always do that for example care
now suppose that I want 0.2 is low and
0.8 with I can you do that and the enter
turns out to be no so if you try to fill
in the question marks together you know
that the average of this guy and this
guy this guy and so on you will not be
able to do that if you constrain the
probabilities are between 0 and 1 so how
do you know that you cannot well
basically border gives a completely
general solution to these types of
questions so the input if you wish to
border serum is the question suppose I'm
giving you the probabilities so each
player can have one of em differ
values each of em players can have one
of em different values and I'm telling
you the probability that it went for
each one of these values get em
probabilities for each player which are
the probability that he wins for each
one of his types Jewish and so let's
call this X IJ the probability that I
ones of this type is J and the question
is does exist an auction with this
winning problem which gives you this
winning probabilities and for now it's
just a question about probability
nothing more than that so I'm just
asking for the other is this like a
tensor so it's going to be a Maitre you
know 1 and n dimensional matrix is any
numbers on each side where the averages
work out according to the xij the
question can you have that so when
you're given this sequence of M times n
numbers and the question is yes or no
can you figure that out or not and
border answer is completely and this is
the file this is a question so here's a
definite definitely a necessary
condition for you being able to do that
if you look at you fix a subset of I of
values for the first player subset of
values for the second player and so on
and now you sum these probabilities so
so you get at that point at least superb
you get it most supporting there's a
probability that the first player wins
when he's in this set and the or the
second player wins win is in that set
and so on we haven't touched any of the
probabilities that someone wins we're
there in the compliment so none of the
players in these sets so of course if
you sum all these numbers up you can get
you must have to get at most one because
otherwise you promised too much power
balti right because the probabilities
its left after without touching these
values the values that we're not talking
about has to somehow be split among
these end players so obviously these are
necessary conditions and border says
that these are is sufficient conditions
so just about mutation when I say the
probability of you know Cartesian
product is just if I have a uniform
distribution which I'm still thinking
about although it doesn't really matter
in general it adjusts are the you know
the product of the ratios of the
relative sizes of the sets that I chose
that's very easy of course by the way a
border be an economist he brought that
with integrals but that's the basic idea
so let's say it in a graphical way and
so I want to know so suppose I have
these numbers these five numbers here
and these six numbers ears ears are
supposed to be the interim probabilities
the probabilities of the second player
winning these are supposed to be the
player probability the first player
winning so of course we must have that
the probability is that this guy wins
here plus our probability that this
guy's wind plus a probability that none
of them is in one of the red states all
that has to be at most one and if you
take that's obvious and if you think all
of these things that's sufficient it
turned out very nice and beautiful syrup
and by the way so when I said two years
so apparently border so there is some
history and now talk about it but border
proves the serum twice a and after it
proved it in 91 16 years later I said oh
by the way you can just use it with
dwell it was linear programming duality
so the first proof was sort of
complicated then the second was very
know-it-all substantial could use
specialized ha okay so okay so now I'm a
bit fudge you hear about how general I
want to be if you're so one thing that's
obvious if we're thinking about the
uniform distribution let's say over the
rows and columns then of course the
tight sets are the ones without a with
the largest exes so you might as well if
you order the excess from the highest to
the lowest you might take a prefix to
the left right
okay so what's the difference or so far
I just talked about probabilities I want
to go one step towards the object so
what's missing between the seduction
well first of all a so far our types
were just the indices but really in an
auction setting the types come with a
real type with a real value for getting
the item so each player also has values
for each one of his possible state and
the value is very important because
that's the main point of how much is he
willing to pay for the item and also a
auction we have to tell how many how
much these guys are going to pay when
they win it's not just what's the
probability of winning and really for
everything that we do if we're going to
be Asian so we only we are worried about
the expected payment so we're going to
have these numbers p IJ what is the
expected payment of player I when he has
type j we also will have these things
and then there are also constraints
which actually said this is really an
auction players don't want to deviate
and the contracts come to come in basic
constraints are we have individual
rationality that I want to I want to
participate meaning i'm not going to pay
more than what I again and incentive
compatibility I'm not going to deviate
from what I equilibrium says I should be
doing and they're the only thing that
the trigger completely standard very
simple and the important things that i
want to say here is that these
constraints are linear in the variables
xij and p IJ so they are linear in them
just normal linear constraints both
these guys and these guys v there now
constants and there are very few of them
okay so there that's the only thing
that's important okay so why why have we
been so interested in the border serum
recently well i mean first of all one
thing is border serum but itself is like
a co MP characterization of being in to
set because it tells you what
constraints but it turns out you can
actually make this into an algorithm so
can actually tell given these numbers
does it work or doesn't it work and once
you have this then you immediately get
for free something amazing you can do
computational mechanism design it almost
for free so suppose I wanted to answer
the following press which question
suppose I wanted to find one item option
that optimizes something that involves
revenue and welfare and payments of
certain players and utilities of other
play mins and probability of winning the
viet other players and have some kind of
linear combination of these different
gold which are basically all the types
of things we care about an auction
design how would i do that how would i
optimize find the optimal auction
process so you know my song can tell me
exactly how to only optimize revenue
maybe a little bit more but suppose i
have a general kind of thing how do i
optimize and the answer is ah we can do
linear programming how do we do a linear
program well we have a basically an LP
characterization now as far a far set of
auctions so it turns out the set of all
possible options are exactly the ones
that satisfies the conditions of the
probabilities work out according to
border serum plus all the incentive
constraints that I had in the previous
slide so I just optimize over the set of
things and to optimize over the set
these are going to be my variables a few
of them they're going to be two types of
constraints so if you wish strategic
ones from the previous slide which are
the nice thing about them there are very
few of them there are going to be like
the border constraints which are many of
them but at least we know what they are
so we can handle them algorithmically
using this and then we can optimize
whatever we want which is beautiful and
it's a very general and strong zero okay
you don't need border for that no just
compactified gives you less exactly so
the only thing the only two okay so the
fact that its border but notice how I've
set it up i'm talking about it about
immediately already only talking what's
called the reduced form so i have a
small number of Erebus if you want to do
it in the original things you get an
exponential thing so I'm already talking
about the in the reduced form and we
look about the reduced form the problem
is can you characterize this poll
opinion or polytope you know many things
there are these huge politics which we
can't touch and we can't optimize over
but once you have voter serum and the
sip yeah
this practical implementation of it you
can you have the exact poet open you can
optimize nicely okay so that's what you
need to do okay so this is all very nice
and now the question is okay can we
generalize it so you know what option of
one item is definitely the first problem
you would consider in mechanism design
but not the last one so you know we have
project public project that you have
multi-item auctions and you have lots
and lots of different type of mechanism
design problems and can you generalize
border serum to be useful whenever
you've generalize border serum you can
exert again gets completely general
mechanism design kind of a polynomial
design which would be great and there's
been of course lots of work on this in
our community in the last few years and
I think there are basically two types of
extensions known one of them just slide
generalizations to a where you actually
get a nice border complete border serum
for example I think he and talked about
the example where you have auctions of
multiple unrelated items where you get
an exact generalization of border
theorem and he presented zetas nice talk
and there are also other very very
general for almost any mechanism design
problems you can think of but these are
only approximate computational so
approximate computational is it may be
annoying for two reasons for the you
know computational one its approximate
that says so sad we wanted not to be
approximate for servicemen mathematical
point of view the fact that its
computational you don't get like a nice
set if equalities like in border that's
sort of annoying i would say for
economist as well so the question is
they okay we would like to do better how
much can you can you can you actually do
exactly deterministically by giving a
nice set of equalities like you know you
would expect a generalization of a
mathematical theorem to be
okay so that's basically our question
hey can we get border border
characterizations for more general
things and let me just say so what is
the border like serum so one thing that
immediately should be immediately clear
is that the set of possible vectors of
probabilities the set of feasible
evaluate the set of these feasible
interim allocations that's clearly a
polytope you can see it's just a
projection of a higher dimensional one
it's obviously a polytope so is obvious
we are going to be a bunch of
inequalities does it define it of course
what we want is very explicit ones and
explicit probably will also i mean if so
explicit is not always exactly the same
thing for a computer scientist and
mathematician we're going to take the
computer science point of view explicit
means that you can recognize them you
know when something is an inequality you
can check whether the inequality holds
definitely border has that things and if
you'd if that's not the case then we
have invoke I don't know the crystals
paradigm which says that computational
nastiness implies mathematical nastiness
okay so it's almost so you know if this
is going to be bad from if you don't
have an explicit computational thing
then probably the explicit mathematical
thing will be difficult although you can
always a you know attacks christos
paradigm and the basic question is no
basically what has been done is what is
possible it's been extended as much as
possible and beyond that it's going to
be terrible and it's going to be
something to something like sharp be
hard to do better border okay so it's a
sharpie art to get the serum so i will
say exactly what that means but
basically the madrigals a statement that
we have said unless you know bad things
happen in complexity and definitely
sharply contains B to the N P that
considered a bad thing the hierarchy
collapses in the bank among other things
hey I don't have that's bad but there
you're not going to be able to do it for
almost anything that you want to do that
they don't know how to do now okay and
how does the provo okay so notice that
I'm using a computational intractability
kind of assumption complexity in the
future computational sense and my
surmise the outcome of what I'm saying
is that oh you're not going to get a
mathematical theorems that economist may
like okay so so that's sort of the you
know and I say kind of application and
basically the the logic will be is a
following logic we're going to show
first that if you have a border like
characterization then in some precise
sense the problem of recognizing
feasible interim allocations so you've
given this vector of these vectors of
excess and saying whether yes or no is
it feasible or not so if you have a
board organization that's not going to
be a very difficult problem
computationally and the second thing is
we are going to show that for an
interesting mechanism design problems
this exact same question is going to be
computed difficult computationally and
that would give you the so I ok so the
first part is actually yes trying to
understand the city made the second girl
which is or that you were saying you
know complexity means you're not gonna
get a theorem that economist would like
because there's a generalization of
order to mate roids yeah I think
economist white and so don't satisfy
your property where you get here if you
like ok so let me say so basically what
you're saying is right ok so I think
you're talking about if you wish that
the cracks in the papadimitriou paradigm
which says there are situations where
something is difficult computationally
and yet the mathematician you would say
this is not difficult very nice and the
classic example will be a
multi-dimensional integral where among
to dynamical integral some
mathematicians would say this is
completely fine you know it's closed for
me and computer scientist with a this is
terrible Sharpie hard and this is
exactly so you're right so we
we want people can discuss the crack and
its importance and what happens and I
think all your example will fall exactly
under that crack of the one thing I
would like to say that you're going to
need more than one blog integral of that
form you're going to be like a large
family Mord upon dominum and integrals
otherwise you'd be in the complexity
class Sharpie with or P to the N P with
poly advice and that's again considered
to be bad okay so you really would need
to have super polynomially many bad
integrals for to think but ok but you
could be so so I don't want to so that's
a really fascinating discussion how much
computational complexity cannon for you
about mathematical nastiness and when is
it not the case hey okay everything
discrete here how do you guys get into
this picture so the integrals good so
intervals as you know I immediately
translate anyway integrals to Sigma's
and you have an n-day an N dimensional
integral that an N dimensional signal so
your end sums and enzymes but one side
the other right one inside the other
right okay so and in so basically you're
summing over exponentially many things
that's going to be that okay okay so
okay so let's say so why is it true that
if we have a border like
characterization things are going to be
a little bit easy because the border
like characterization basically what it
means that you have you can tell whether
some kind of inequality is the quiet the
facet of this polytope and of course you
can figure out whether you're inside or
outside so we're so it basically means a
computational sense it means that you
can recognize when something is outside
you have approved when something is
outside of the polytope so at least that
gives you like a co MP kind of cowardice
and being outside so the whole ellipsoid
saying will be a p2 the co NT kind of
thing so that would give you a pizza
so okay so the colonization would be in
the class code co MP that would be
completely obvious okay because that's
exactly what the border says so it's not
going to be too difficult and and what
do I mean by saying that for certain
problems this is going to be hard to
actually a touch and you recognize a
feasible interim allocation rule so
we're going to actually show we're going
to actually describe a very simple
public project setting for which to
realize whether you can get these
probabilities or not is going to be
Sharpie hard so this is a boolean
decision problem and the Sharpie
hardness would be under curing
reductions which is good enough for
everything that we do okay so here is
the problem for which I want to show
this sharpie hardness and this is really
the simplest kind of mechanism design
things that you can have in almost
anything else they worked we have a few
other examples what you're saying is
that that model of or characterization
intervene everything else is easy
everything else is busy yes that already
I had in the previous night right so
yeah that I had even before that module
ooh border a rock sorry I'm going the
opposite way yes and so when I say
suppose I want to optimize this kind of
various thing the whole point was that
module border everything is it is here
everything is just LP okay
this is the size of the problem because
again you in the size of the reduced
problem i'm already in the reduced world
original right that's a claim and so I
in my setup I didn't have an original
problem i only had the reduced problem
okay so why I mean reduce forums you can
you can solve the design perfectly the
only obstacle to finding the best with
it use forum is okay okay it's a pun on
hotel separation Oracle for this family
of inequalities I guess and that's of
Isis yes but there is a state finding
the optimal option without seeing the
point that the point of the ball the
previous what is it that's exactly the
point yes it does say yes exactly the
point that it does say yes it does say
and not only does it say it it says it
if you look already long because the
first you need to think a little to go
to the reduced thing but once you think
already in the reduced thing there's
nothing to prove except saying all do
will be okay so here's the problem i'm
going to look at and i am I trying to
make it as the boolean ish as possible
for a mechanism design problem so we
need to decide whether to build a bridge
or not so the output is going to be yes
or no and they're going to be n player
then each one is going to have a value
whether he wants a bridge to be built or
not and we're going to talk about a very
simple discrete kind of valuation a set
with probability one-half I don't care
if the bilges bridges built and with
probability one-half I'm going to gain
utility WI where WI depends on I and
it's publicly known for everyone and and
the question is doing basic revenue
maximization and and the question is
doing basic revenue maximization of this
kind of thing ok and I'm going to show
that that cannot be done that's a
sharpie heart problem ok so now let's go
again so why is a fact that I can't do a
maximization thing and this kind of
thing how does that go back to border
because as we already saw if you do have
better you can do can optimize anything
that relates to revenue and money and
the other things and you would be able
to do this okay so the fact that I shows
that you cannot figure out the possible
maximum possible revenue immediately
implies that you should they're not able
to do computation leagues are just the
border itself because that's the only
bottlenecks you have ok so one thing is
it should already look a little bit
suspicious to all economists here
because this is definitely within the
meyerson framework it single dimensional
so you can find the optimal auction in
fact I'll tell you what it is in a
second so how can I say that it's going
to be difficult to find the revenue well
because it's going to be difficult to
find the revenue even though you know
what's auction is okay so the problem is
given WI what is the bet optimal auction
I'm going to tell you it's very easy and
Meyer Sun in fact elements very easy the
question is given the w's what is the
revenue of that optimal action that is
the difficult thing so why do we care
about what the revenue is well you know
for the most curious to know that you
can't figure out the revenue even do you
know what the auction is but we care in
our situation because if you had border
you could also figure out the revenue
sheriff II hardness typically sampling
will give you very good as a good
approximation and we said sample and get
very good absolutely and in fact we know
if we mentioned before we have very
general positive results if you allow
yourself approximation and randomization
right and definitely the general the
very general ones includes this problem
as more as well as many more much more
difficult ones so we know how to do a
proximate randomized mechanism design
here completely yeah I guess I I feel
that there's a difference between an
exactness that comes from sampling and
an exactness that comes from say
anywhere else I I can believe that but
that to the saying was the limit of
border serum and good very good argument
that there is a limit here that doesn't
mean that this is hard to go because as
we know we know what the optimum an ism
is so this not hard to do but you still
can't have a borders for the serum here
because if you did then you could get
this except the approximate for
appearance the only bottleneck is also
something so something like
okay so what is the optimal mechanism
for this so you can do it in two ways
one of them is just do arrow it just do
my own son sorry hey I used for most
other questions is just the word about
there okay so you just do my your son
and basically the questions that optimal
is the optimal auction is the way the
special is a weighted threshold function
so you some the weights of the guys want
the bridge so that happened to have WI
and you compute it so that it gets a
value W is and you compute the sum of
these values some of these weights to
the weight of the guys who are
indifferent about the bridge so they
really don't care if you build the
bridge but because they were different
we're going to be they're going to vote
against and if the threshold if you're
above the threshold you build a bridge
and otherwise you don't build a bridge
and you can actually see that the amount
of revenue give you get from that is
basically the amount of a when you get
from the ice player from the ice bidder
is basically his gain his game from
moving from the zeroes out come to the
one outcome which is a difference of
probabilities time is x is WI okay and
some of this is so the fact that given a
function this is up this is the revenue
you get can really get from it this is
completely basic you can just go and do
it yourself immediately there's nothing
to it the fact that this is the optimal
thing you can do by your son and now the
second way you could do it if you're
from the other workshops it's going on
here this is really basically the
weighted maximizing the weighted sum of
influences of a sort of boolean function
and if we want to maximize the sum of
influences we know that majority does it
and if you do it in our four years
transform kind of ways these elements
are really the the first of the Fourier
coefficients of the singleton items and
so there is a very easy and well-known
proof that's a better map majority
maximizes the sum of influences the same
proof immediately gives you that
weighted majority which is the threshold
function what maximizes the sum of
weighted influences the weighted sum of
influences and in fact that gives you an
alternative for persons proof that this
is optimal auction at least in this case
so okay but that was a shout out for the
other okay so now the only questions
that we really need to know how
difficult it is to compute this son okay
very simple because it has really a
probability there so the point is each
one of these probabilities things is
really an exponential kind of average
average of among exponentially many kind
of things of course you can sample it
but can you compute it exactly so it
turns out that it's hard that you would
expect anyone to see that kind of thing
you can figure out it was difficult so
this is our computational problem you
get your w's you want to estimate you
want to calculate not estimate you want
to calculate the probabilities awaited
some of the differences of influences
here and how difficult is that problem
so if you look at it a bit well let's
suppose one of the w's is really small
one of the w's is really small there's
no one we can always add it for a
reduction so it's one of the w that's
really small is only have going to have
influence it's the other guys that are
exactly tied and also from the anthro we
can read out exactly the probabilities
as other guys are tight so it means that
if I could do this I could figure out
whether there's a body the probability
that the other guys are tied the
probability that the other guys are tied
well that's sort of like a this exactly
a sharp partition problem if you wish
because being tied you ever want to
think some positive some negative can
you split it into two sets that they
have the same thing and char partition
is really a very close cousin of sharp
knapsack which is there already one of
the you know at this point it's Sharpie
heart okay it's a Turing reduction yeah
all my reduction they're touring
productions so we didn't care so much
since anyways I LP was a touring kind of
thing so we weren't they okay so so
that's a delicate thing so we're talking
like here a yeah so I'm not sure and so
okay I i was wondering also about that
and i started fingering it out but i
never finished so i think something is
known as something else is not known I
couldn't figure out if I guess this is
also complete under the normal kind of
sharpie reductions
yeah open issues in the shooting yeah
okay so so I don't know so the statement
it is certain curing complete I probably
it's also normal complete but I don't
know okay so that basically finishes the
proof I mean if you believe this slide
which is really an extra below an
exercise so basically what is we shown
for a public project for the public
boolean the pup for the boolean public
project mechanism design was just chosen
to be and one end as close as possible
to what we do in boolean functions and
on the other hand it's really one of the
simplest kind of a make an ensign
problems that you have and if you want
to do almost anything else it's embedded
somewhere there we show that computing
the optimal revenue is going to be hard
computationally and that implies that
there's not going to be bordered serum
for this very simple instance of an
option problem
it seems to be the separate the boundary
between places where we have borders
like this place will be dumb is major on
see the photo focused over the border
aborted it the maker if you economics
okay so okay so you're saying this
hearing from your point of view of when
it didn't look nice mathematically to
your eyes it's Metroid's which is a
farther along than what computation is a
situation and it would be really nice if
you could quantify that mathematically
that you know if I allow myself this
types of integral then I could go only
this and that's their a I don't know how
to do that because if you allow yourself
like sampling you can go all the way so
you write the same thing but tell mama
so if if you take as equation initially
had but you put the expected rank of the
matrix 0 at the probabilities that you
have in the sets then you get a border
sphere information waves okay and so you
get the mathematic equation on one side
you get an expectation of the expected
ranked according adventurer okay and
this is a very succinct nice description
of an even finer the problem is major
eight said that there is an exponential
amount of improv here because you have
to derank function it so captain
expected rank function is you know
approximate you can approximate it but
it
a special number of inequalities but
doesn't have exponential amount of input
you can compactly sick of what they are
ResMed function is sort of intellectual
in your head combat but I can't give it
to you as an input it's a clarity of
what is the debate for a description in
the first place which is exponential
itself there is no complete description
of matrix I mean for many there are okay
like I got a graphical may try this the
graphical may try to contact employee
okay so you can have 16 to application
of certain Metroid's that's true but
then it may be so mean of course at the
end we all know it's going to be
computationally sharply hard to actually
compute these expected ranks of even if
you give a succinctly and definitely if
you give a non succeed point right so I
mean I think it would be really nice so
this is like a more general kind of
thing of the hope up at the meteor
paradigm that if you showed something is
hard computationally it means that it's
bad mathematically this is like a big
crack everywhere and it will be nice to
be able to go even a little step more
further than you know what's really
pianet over or you know easy computation
or not to show not only the difficult
computationally but even if we allow
mathematicians to do these types of
integrals or these type of sampling you
can't do this that would be really nice
so just to be clear though so a step
back from all mate roids is the uniform
a droid so two units one item what so I
don't think we have a result for that
either side all rights also so we have
like a bunch of examples it doesn't
cover where it's hard so we know for
things like matching for single-minded
bitter so we have a bunch of results
where it's hard we sort of thought it
covered almost anything that would think
of but very like possibly there are more
thing that did not fall under our
impossibility and are not yet known
they're not much there but definitely
there could be interesting things there
I I don't have an exhaustive map of very
in my